foreign
[Music]
news briefing for Tuesday October 25th
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal
the chip industry is in a period of
transition Intel which reports earnings
later this week has been hit hard by a
recent softening of demand for
semiconductors but the company has also
had some recent wins including the
passage of the bipartisan chips act
that'll pour about 52 billion dollars
into expanding domestic production of
chips and Intel is betting big on U.S
production with plans to build foundries
in Ohio and Arizona as Western companies
look to break their Reliance on Asian
Supply chains Intel CEO Patrick
gelsinger kicked off our Tech live
conference yesterday speaking about this
and more with wsj editor Thorold Barker
here are highlights from their
conversation hello everybody and Pat
welcome to Tech live thanks very much
for coming to be our first Speaker we've
got a lot of ground to cover so for the
last few years we've read endlessly
about the shortage of chips in the world
and not be able to get enough for cars
and other things that seems to have now
flipped into a different situation where
there's an excess of chips and prices
have come down and you've had some
pretty tough tough earnings you've been
in the industry a long time is this a
chip cycle or is this an economic
recession that you're looking at well
obviously chips are super important to
the planet right you know it's why we
saw the chips act why we saw you know
all this discussion around uh chips uh
broadly and you know the expectation is
by the end of the decade the chips
industry approximately doubles you know
today about 600 billion by the end of
the decade 1.1 trillion right in that
view so you clearly have a growing
industry long term so fundamentally we
have a long-term growth cycle in front
of us and we have near-term wild Cycles
right obviously you know the
covid-induced cycle where sort of
overnight right we saw Supply chains
disrupted so Supply decreased by
five-ish percent on an industry that
typically is growing by five percent per
year five six percent per year and
demand went to 25 percent per year so
all of a sudden you see this huge
acceleration and demand right decrease
in Supply disruptions and Supply chains
right and I'll just say the over
stimulation of the economies around the
world and clearly that was most
accentuated in the semiconductor
industry well now we're catching up
right you've seen the economy slow down
around the world Supply chains for the
first time you know so it really is one
of those Cycles but it's against the
backdrop where the industry is going to
double this decade so we have to keep
building those long-term Factory build
outs even though we have to make
near-term adjustments and price
variations right in dealing with you
know Shanghai port shutdowns and so on
it's been a pretty dramatic you know a
year and a half so you've been in
Washington a lot helping to push through
the chips act how Reliant is Intel now
on subsidy going forward
first let's contextualize the chips act
right and we have the U.S chips Act and
the EU chips act you know if we were
building Manufacturing in Asia you know
the expectations and Sia estimates say
it'd be 30 or 40 percent cheaper if we
were building in Asia Supply chains are
now firmly Consolidated there it is
simply economically uncompetitive to
build in U.S or Europe and that's why we
saw the industry move from 80 20 in 1990
in U.S and Europe to 2080 today you know
it's been a dramatic shift over the last
30 years so the chips Act was balancing
you know essentially leveling that
playing field so your strategy would
still have been the same in terms of
both the design and the production of
chips you'd have just been doing it
somewhere else absolutely it has to be
competitive when you're moving that
level of investment right got to be
competitive so a lot of this is about
China can you talk a little bit about
what your view is on the latest rules
out of the byte Administration to stop
technology transfer both in terms of the
technology itself and the people doing
that what is your take on this is this a
good thing I think it was inevitable
right you know when you know this view
of how something so critical to every
industry every business and are we going
to you know be able to continue to have
leadership on those Technologies part of
the reason I've been such an advocate
for many of these policies I viewed this
geopolitically as inevitable and that's
why the rebalancing of Supply chains it
was so critical right you know are we
going to have the supply chains that we
need for our Autos you know for our AI
for our national security for game
consoles for our PCS when you were
loving for the chips that were you also
pushing for this no no but you're
welcoming of it yeah I you know clearly
expected this uh to be the case it was
part of the reason that I've always used
the phrase geographically balanced
resilient Supply chains you know Taiwan
plays such a critical role you know for
the technology Supply chains but it's
precarious even the Taiwanese vendors
believe deeply they need their supply
chains to become more balanced so you
know I view this very inevitable right
as we look to the Future and given that
you know none of the policies that are
you know being put in place by I don't
think any of us would be surprised by
that and just quickly what is the gap
like now between Chinese capability and
Western capability yeah today you know
the most advanced in China right is
about 14 nanometers uh today you know
different different estimates uh today
you know we're doing uh seven nanometers
about to do four right tsmc and taiwan's
about to start their three production
and you know we're racing to have our
sub two nanometers by 2025. you know
when the policies that you've seen are
basically to maintain or increase that
gap between where China is all right and
where U.S or european capabilities uh
would be great thank you very much Pat
all right that's it for today's Tech
news briefing Tech live continues
tomorrow for live coverage of the event
visit our website wsj.com and journal
subscribers can get a complimentary
online pass at wsj.com Tech live I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]